I think there's something magical when
chefs meet each other mostly because
most chefs are so kind and so nice and
know what we go through within the
industry but more than anything we're
also Perpetual lifelong students
wherever we're eating whatever we're
eating whoever we're eating with huge
objective of ours is to understand the
deliciousness felt very much at home and
at ease with Chef because he was so
happy to to teach me things I didn't
know I'm sorry to ask this but can I
take a photo of
you
[Music]
as a chef I don't think I'm ever going
to get this opportunity ever again to
sit in a restaurant with the chef and
ask so many probing questions and meet
the chef who is so open to answering
those questions and and genuinely
helping me understand a little bit more
about the evolution and the movement of
sushi Through the
Ages